the gyro can experience I really believe
that to truly be to have optimum
performance and to be and to be optimum
that you have to have the whole every
spoke in the tire that you need every
single spoke that you have to have a
good relations with your family you got
to have love and you got to have good
things with the kids and you got to have
friends and you got to have your health
and you got to sleep well and you got to
be hydrated and you got to work out and
you got it and you got to have a you
know your business thing and you got to
have I think you just have to have all
these things to really have balance and
I think if you if if one of the spokes
isn't tight that there's a bump in the
wheel and then you're just not gonna I
don't truly believe that that you you're
performing at your optimum because you
need your head needs to be clear when
you go into your performance whatever
that looks like I think that's excellent
advice I think that makes a lot of sense
and it definitely keeps your mind clear
you know you have your bases covered
covered
you're not just you're not here but
there but somewhere else I mean and I
know I've dealt with not being having
all the spokes good and I know that the
how that feels and I know when it's good
you're clear you're good you're you're
you're and it's how we're meant to be I
mean we're meant to have that be real
clean we're meant to have that there be
some sense balance not to have it yeah
that's why I mean even over working
people think that you know they think
that's a badge of honor yeah yeah like
oh yeah I work my thing and I don't
sleep and do them like yeah well then
you're compromising yourself I told the
Elan must that did you yeah I was I went
to SpaceX one time and I pulled him
aside he was standing on to go hey you
know you have to take care of this I put
my hand on his chest I just go you take
care of this but you got to take care of
you what'd he say he just yeah I don't
know if he understood he's about he I
don't think he barely a person I'm just
saying I don't think with all due
respect and yeah but I don't think he
understood what I meant I didn't I felt
like you know as someone like that if
they were really taking good care of
themselves
getting the right sleep getting in the
right food getting a workout all those
things imagine right imagine like if
they can do what they're doing you know
burning it on both ends imagine what
they could do fully balanced well I
don't think he wants to do anymore
than what he's doing I just think he's
so obsessed with getting Tesla to run
correctly he was sleeping on the floor
of the Tesla factory and working 17
hours a day I mean that's that is that's
an insane person I mean he was just
there all day long trying to make it
work and obviously it does work they're
amazing cars yeah everything's yeah it's
it's beneficial yeah that this drive
that he has but I agree with you like
for overall enjoyment of life that's not
the way to go but I think you have a
blockage there though - I think if you
don't can't pull back and look at it
from a distance you and you're in it I
think you get too detailed and then you
can't you know you you can't be I think
you I think it could be better because
of that I think maybe maybe it'd be
profitable I mean you're you're
competing against you know the big boys
Yeah right but what's interesting is
loyal even though they are doing that
they've managed to he's managed to make
something that's so different than
anything else you have one that now I
don't [ __ ] man they're crazy yeah III
was reluctant I told my Bible when he
did the podcast yeah but I was like god
damn and I liked muscle cars all hearing
engines but I drove that thing I was
like oh other cars are stupid they're
all today but they are their archaic
they are tired of that thing they are
wealthy and you see all the companies
going that way now you see I mean we
were because my buddy Waldman and I were
into electric stuff and and we went and
there was a guy that has an electric
dragster and we went down and with this
electric geyser and it just smoked any
top fuel dragster like beyond and but it
didn't make noise so no one wanted to
watch it so I mean and you're like what
happened no no no smell no noise no
flames right no don't know it's no
burning gasps no no no pollution
yeah no pollution so people were like oh
that's not fun so yeah but when you
drive a Tesla like I have the Model S
yeah he 100 D I think that's called when
you drive it it's effortless like
everything just you just go where you
want to go like I'd like to be over
there it's like a video yeah like all
sudden you're over there well you have
to get used to it cuz I've been in them
and driven driven them and it's
interesting how the body has to act
to the acceleration because you're used
to that joke oh that's shifting you know
first year second year third gear all
that delay like it's like AC versus DC
normal cars are like AC a little gap
between the power and when you get that
you know it's it's the body has to get
used to the I'm still not totally okay
with not looking where you're going and
just flip it in on autopilot but yeah I
guess that's yeah the next generation
well that's fun on the highway but yeah
you know I look where I'm going they
keep my hand on the wheel but it is fun
to like shut 10% of your brain off and
just let the car kind of handle the
speed one it does it well does it well
does it yeah well I did like I said I
think you need a person who's as
obsessed as Elon Musk is to make
something like that but I agree with you
if if he wants to enjoy his life well
just live longer yeah you have more
ideas more influence like just beyond I
am only speaking that way I just mean in
a way of optimizing him right maizing
him for because of his he's so amazing
you know that
okay let's optimize your amazingness by
by making you like be healthier let me
take care of yourself so you can be
around longer and maybe do more great
things right so it's again I I you know
I'm just speaking personally about when
you try to look at optimization right
like you're here you only get so long
you know what are you doing and and are
you really optimizing it by by you know
burn it by by taxing the system and not
not getting all of it out of it that you
you know but I guess in a way it's kind
of like unhappiness you know people use
that as a workout no that's a load that
makes you tired and your get hungry and
you know well it's the choices you make
right like sometimes you just get stuck
in the momentum of the choice that you
made and it's very difficult to like
take that pause and go okay am i doing
this the right way maybe I need a reset
then we need to just take some time a
really consider if this is making me
happy and how many years I'm gonna be
able to do this and sustain it yeah well
that's a tricky thing you know that's a
that's a that's a self self you know
analyzing yourself and putting that up
is I think it's easier just to keep
going the direction or go on
s'matter all and keep it at full speed